an existential haunting that's very
weird I would not think of a haunted
experience an existential in the same
breath does that mean it's gonna like
change me I mean I've read a couple
things online from people who wrote
articles about their experience but it
never really went into detail so kind of
in the dark yeah maybe literally later
tonight we'll see having done this
before I find it is scary but the more I
do it the more well the more excited I
am tomorrow I realize this is more about
wonderment it's all about like getting
inside your head and freaking you out on
this deeper level which is what I'm
really excited about I don't know if I
like that that's uh that's a little
creepy
we see people coming out like over here
sometimes you see them all messed up and
you're like oh I don't really know what
to expect with this I'm scared I'm not
going I'm a little scared
I don't know what they're gonna do to me
hopefully I'm here tomorrow
so it's really cool but it was really
weird I don't know like it was haha I
just walked out of there it was a little
bit more like erotic than I was
expecting every room I was confused and
just disoriented it like I could you
play it on your like I guess basic beers
I never really knew what was going on
but it was really fun no one really like
jumped out at you they weren't just kind
of like crapped on she would like guided
you through this like crazy like mental
experience it was really rad I would
definitely do it again
I was like tripping like stone there's
nothing
yeah I do like I Drive home now am i
under the influence